Welcome, everybody. It's a pleasure and an honor to welcome you to
this session on the comparison of solid and liquid
tumors. We have three speakers, and all of
you, I was reminded to, should capture the QR code
in case you want to ask questions directly through the
chat. So we'll have a
part of myself, I'm Hugues de The from Collège de France in Paris, and we also
have then Christopher Sierra-Casas from Harvard
School of Public Health,
Luca Mazzarella from European Institute of Oncology in
Milan,
and we'll be discussing different aspects of this
comparison. If I could have the first slide, please.
So,
one of the differences between solid and liquid tumors
is that we have probably more examples of
direct cures of liquid tumors such as leukemia
than solid tumors. And so I decided to review with
you our work on
the cure of acute promyelocytic leukemia.
So just a few words of comparison in, we have more examples where
liquid tumors such as APL or childhood
ALL, are more highly curable than with targeted or
chemotherapy.
Only very few solid tumors are, and this of course
begs the question of why. One
thing that was proposed is that tumor growth is
more rapid in liquid tumors. Perhaps also there is a better access to
the drugs. We have better targeted drugs.
Tumor genetics is clearly more simple in the case of
the liquid tumors, probably less
intratumoral heterogeneity as well, distinct metabolism,
easier clearance of cancer cells post-chemotherapy, easier
immune activation, others. And I'll review with you what I've been
working on the past 30 years, which is one disease,
APL,
for which all of this is quite well understood.
And these ideas were discussed in a number of
recent reviews, including one with Tony Letai, the current
head of the NCI here.
So acute promyelocytic leukemia is characterized by a
specific translocation between two genes, PML and the
retinoic acid receptor gene, which creates a PML-RER
fusion
that
is really the unique monogenic driver of the
disease. This fusion binds retinoic acid,
binds DNA, deregulates retinoic acid signaling, and is
clearly the basis for the exquisite retinoic acid
sensitivity of this condition.
So there are some very specific features of APL, which
likely explains why this is probably the only
example of a condition which is always cured by targeted therapy.
One of them is that the epidemiology of the disease shows a constant
incidence with age, which points to a single rate-limiting step,
and this step is the formation of the PML-RER fusion.
Clinically,
retinoic acid or arsenic trioxide are able to induce
terminal differentiation of these leukemic cells.
I'll show you an example in a second.
And these may be cured by a single agent therapy
under some conditions, and it's almost always cured by the combination
of these two drugs. So this begs the question of whether
differentiation induction by those two drugs is the actual basis for
response.
However, work from many groups, including that of Pier Giuseppe
Pelicci or Tim Ley here in the US, have shown that we have some
classic progression events such as MYC amplification,
FLT3 activation, WT1 mutations, which
may be present. But while FLT3 activation has
some prognosis impact on clinical therapy with
retinoic acid outcome, it no longer has any impact on
the effect of retinoic acid arsenic combination
therapy. And as I'll show you in a second, the pathophysiology and the
basis for therapy response are very well understood.
So this was for a long time the classic example of differentiation
therapy wherein myeloid leukemia are characterized by a
stop, an arrest in differentiation at a specific
stage of myeloid leukemia differentiation, and that through the
effect of agents such as retinoic acid, this
interrupted differentiation process will be restored, and this can
be shown on this slide here, where you can see
pre-treatment bone marrow and post a week of retinoic
acid, you can see clearly differentiated cells which are of
leukemic origin, and these cells, as all
post-mitotic myeloid cells, ultimately will be
destroyed.
However,
except in some very specific conditions, retinoic acid is not
curative in this condition. Moreover, work of several
groups in the field has shown that retinoic acid in some
variant APLs can induce differentiation but
is not curative in any way.
So the molecular pathogenesis worked out by many groups
all over Europe, China, US, has shown that PML-RER
is a transcription factor with altered properties, which
behaves
as a repressor of retinoic acid signaling.
And in the presence of high-dose retinoic acid, this
repressive effect will be abolished and replaced by a transactivating
effect, leading to the reactivation of retinoic acid target
genes, differentiation, and clinical remission.It
was also shown, and this has now become extremely fashionable at the
moment with the biology of condensates, that PML, the normal PML
protein, is present as a number of aggregates in the
nucleus named PML nuclear bodies, and that the expression of
PML-RAR will disrupt these aggregates in
APL cells into what we call the micro speckle nucleus staining,
representing the dissociation of these
aggregates. And interestingly, treatment with retinoic acid or
with arsenic will restore the formation of these structures, and
we'll see why
in a second.
So among the features of APL
pathogenesis and therapy response, it's very clear from, again, work
of many groups over the past 30 years, that deregulation of
retinoic acid signaling is absolutely central to the initiation
of the disease because all APL-like leukemias
involve alteration of retinoic acid receptor, which can be RAR
alpha, but also in very rare cases, RAR gamma or
RAR beta. This can be through various
genetic events, most classically fusions, but it can also
be fusion plus deletion, viral insertion, or mere
overexpression.
And this, again, is primarily through RAR alpha,
which potently represses transcription.
And work from several groups has shown that
repression is required for immortalization of leukemic cells, although the
downstream target genes are not identified.
However, PML is absolutely key for cure, and only
APL driven by PML-RAR will exhibit prolonged response to
retinoic acid. And as we'll see in a second, PML is targeted
by arsenic to control senescence.
So what are these aggregates which I showed a
second ago, these PML nuclear bodies?
It's a very interesting structure wherein PML creates
a partitioning within the nucleus, allowing the recruitment of
many partner proteins through
mechanisms involving a SUMO conjugation site and a SUMO
interacting motif. And this has been implicated in antitumor
and antiviral function. And this was linked to
multiple types of stress responses, notably p53 signaling and
senescence.
Interestingly, in non-APL or APL cells, arsenic
trioxide has this remarkable property of directly targeting the
PML protein to induce the formation of these bodies in
vivo, as you can see here in liver
cells in vivo of
arsenic-treated mice. And this is through a
polymerization mechanism which was worked in the lab,
mostly by Valerie Lallement, and this is accompanied by the
destruction of the PML protein or PML-RAR protein
by a new SUMO-mediated degradation
pathway.
The binding site of arsenic on PML or PML-RAR
was recently identified and shown to involve a specific
cysteine residue, which in the context of a trimer, forms
a triad of cysteine residues, which is a perfect arsenic binding site
explaining the sensitivity of this condition to arsenic, and
importantly, in rare arsenic-resistant patients,
mutations of the alpha helix that allows the
formation of this trimer and therefore position these
cysteine residues were found in a tri-resistant APL.
So can we unify those two therapies?
And this was made through the realization
that both targeted drugs, retinoic acid and arsenic,
actually share the ability to trigger the degradation of the
PML-RAR driving oncogenes directly by
binding
its RAR and PML moiety and triggering
biochemical degradation pathways which have been
largely deciphered in the lab involving
ubiquitination by UBR5, recruitment of the
proteasome, and degradation for retinoic acid, and binding
onto the specific site that I just showed you in the PML
part of PML or PML-RAR, inducing
conjugation by SUMO, recruitment of the SUMO-dependent ubiquitin
ligase, polyubiquitination, proteasome recruitment, and
degradation of this protein.
Importantly, as I was mentioning in the beginning, PML-RAR has the
ability to disrupt PML nuclear bodies, as you can see here
on the left part of the figure representing APL blast in
patients, and treatment with retinoic acid in vivo
or arsenic. This is a historical slide taken from the original paper.
In fact,
it precedes the differentiation and precedes the elimination of the
disease, suggesting that this reformation of PML nuclear bodies
could actually participate to therapeutic
response. Interestingly, there
was a demonstration-- I'm sorry, this is the N-1
version of the talk.
The slides are not in the proper order.
So there's altered
global SUMO2 homeostasis in PML null cells
because PML has the ability to recruit the SUMO
machinery, including the SUMO ubiquitin ligase,
SUMO ligase UBC9, to promote protein
sumoylation and also then through the
recruitment of RNF4 to promote protein
degradation as a result of the reformation of these
PML nuclear bodies upon oxidative stress, which controls a
senescence reaction.So the
physiopathology of the condition was worked through mouse modeling,
by many groups, showing that
reactivation of transcriptional control
through the binding of retinoic acid or the degradation
of PML-RER by arsenic controls differentiation.
So restoration of transcriptional control allows
differentiation of these leukemic cells into granulocytes, while the
degradation of PML-RER
allowed by treatment with retinoic acid, arsenic, or
their combination allows the reformation of PML nuclear
bodies, the activation of p53, as well
as other pathways which control loss of self-renewal and are
absolutely required for a therapeutic response in
vivo, and indeed in mouse models, it was shown that
deleting either PML or p53
abolishes therapeutic response while maintaining differentiation,
implying the differentiation was not the sole driving force
for a therapeutic response in this condition.
How does PML activate
p53 remains a matter of discussion.
However, multiple groups have shown that PML has the
ability to recruit p53 and most of its modifying
enzyme to allow optimal p53
modification, allowing then p53 to
become a major pro-senescence driver, and indeed,
PML is absolutely required for senescence in
multiple conditions, including oncogene-induced
senescence.
So interestingly, while it was believed as long as
differentiation was thought to be the driving force for retinoic acid
response, that retinoic acid and arsenic antagonize
one another,
which was true for differentiation, mouse models have all
shown that they in fact synergize dramatically for a
cure, as you can see here, with a dramatic
synergy for the reduction of tumor burden and prolongation
of survival, which actually resulted in all mice being cured and dying of
old age. And this was progressively subsequently
implemented in patients,
showing
in a very famous trial by the late Francesco Lococo,
that the combination of the two drugs without any
chemotherapy could
allow the cure of virtually all patients, and
this now has become the
standard of care all over the world, with the success being
confirmed by a very large number of patients.
So again, coming back to the
mechanisms of
therapy response, we were interested to know why
arsenic is actually a better drug than retinoic acid.
Retinoic acid, I told you, rarely cures any
patient on its own, but arsenic actually can cure up to two-thirds
of the patients as a single agent, which is really remarkable.
I don't know of any other example in cancer therapy of a drug that is so potent.
And through the work of mouse model and also human genetics,
we and others were able to show that indeed, retinoic acid and
arsenic both degrade PML-RER, and this will
result in the de-repression of retinoic acid
targets and differentiation. At the same time, degradation of
PML-RER will allow this reformation of PML nuclear bodies,
which will drive p53 activation, loss of self-renewal
senescence. However, because I told you that arsenic actually
directly targets also the normal PML, in the
presence of arsenic, you will reinforce nuclear body reformation and
therefore super activate p53 and the other senescence
pathway, and this can be shown here on these images
taken from mice treated only six hours in in vivo with a
combination where you can see the restoration of these PML nuclear
bodies in red, which is absolutely dramatic, even before the
complete degradation of PML-RER.
And importantly, this mechanism was demonstrated to be
correct through the exploration of resistant patients that
was carried out primarily in China, demonstrating
that the arsenic binding site that I showed to you in the beginning is
actually mutated in patients which are
unresponsive to arsenic.
But we also described mutations on the normal
PML allele, not on PML-RER, in
therapy-resistant patients, genetically demonstrating that this
activity of arsenic on the normal PML allele
contributes to the cure, so that
arsenic is really an incredible drug, having this property
to both degrade the accelerator and press on the brake,
and this results in the cure of a substantial number of
patients, again, with arsenic as a single therapy.
So in
completing this model, there was a question that was still unaddressed
and that we recently elucidated on trying to know why
PML is the recurrent partner of RER and APL.
Because from what I told you, in principle, any
repression domain translocated onto a retinoic acid
receptor should be able to silence differentiation
gene and promote the disease. And what we stumbled across
in the lab is that in fact, PML brings in
theSUMO E2 ligase
UBC9. And by tethering this
UBC9 onto PML-RAR and RAR
cofactors and notably corepressors,
PML-RAR has this ability to sumonate everything that is
around the PML-RAR binding site, including the
corepressors and other protein. And this
results in super repression, much more potent than
just tethering a repression domain.
And the best proof for this is that when you treat APL
cells driven by PML-RAR but not by
PLZF-RAR
with a sumoylation inhibitor, you will reactivate
retinoic acid signaling only in PML-RAR, not in
PLZF-RAR. And not shown here, this
reactivation of retinoic acid signaling sufficed to induce
differentiation in vivo, therefore conclusively demonstrating
why PML has to be the universal fusion partner in this
condition.
So PML as a model for a targeted therapy, the
expected outcomes have been fulfilled.
Targeting the driver has clinical benefit.
Combinations are curative in virtually all patients.
Mechanisms of transformation and of response
are understood. And actually, in mouse models, immune
clearance is largely dispensable.
So what could be the future of this disease?
To try to identify the retinoic acid receptor downstream
targets which are responsible for enforcing self-renewal, and in
that respect, dominant negative mutations of RAR alpha were
found in some other conditions, including some rare
forms of breast cancers, which show very typical
RAR alpha driving mutations.
And
the last thing that we've been interested in is to trying to know whether this
PML senescence hub could be involved in the response to
other therapies, and this will be just the last
data slide I think I should be showing, work of two PhD
students in the lab showing that in fact, PML is absolutely
required for response to conventional chemotherapy.
This can be seen here. This is an MLL-based fusion
oncogene, very aggressive oncogene,
yielding very aggressive leukemia.
We generate these leukemia in a PML plus or PML minus
background. They have the same
progression. And when you treat with conventional chemotherapy,
a combination of doxorubicin and ara-C, the classic combination
given to patients, you have a sharp survival benefit in the PML
plus cells, much reduced in PML minus,
demonstrating that similar to the APL situation, PML
plays a role in response to conventional chemotherapy.
Moreover, if we sample the bone marrow after five
days of therapy, you can see in this condition with PML
that chemotherapy induces both terminal differentiation of
leukemic cells together with their senescence, as shown
here by the blue staining. Nothing of this occurs in the
absence of PML. No differentiation, no senescence.
And when we perform single-cell sequencing on the most
immature leukemic cells in these conditions, we could see very
clear pathways activated in a PML-dependent
manner. In particular, shutoff of MYC signaling,
shutoff of E2F, which are differentially affected in PML
plus and PML background, while p53
was activated in both setting. And this, of course, greatly
extends the importance of PML in therapy response
away from the APL-only model towards a more
general implication in other conditions.
I'd like to credit my numerous collaborators who've been involved
in this work for a number of years. These are the two places where
I work, the Hopital Saint-Louis and the College de France, and our source of
funding, and I'm happy to take questions.
So please speak to the mic and identify yourselves.
Hi, I'm Saumya
from Memorial Sloan Kettering. You
talked about this paradigm of using ATRA for
differentiation mainly and not being curative,
but when added
arsenic trioxide, it's curative and how
p53 activation may play a role in that.
Keeping that in mind, I was wondering what your views are on
extending this paradigm to other AML
subtypes, where we find
these differentiating inducers plus
adding something that would activate apoptosis
processes.
So I think it's quite clear that the exquisite
sensitivity of this condition to retinoic acid and to arsenic,
of course, is linked to the PML-RAR driver and to the
ability of these two drugs
to fully degrade the
driver. However, the last data slide that I showed on the
importance of PML in response to conventional chemotherapy, I
think raises the possibility that
some of the pathways, deregulation of retinoic acid signaling,
hyperactivation of PML-driven senescence through the
control of sumoylation, I didn't show that data, but we have
this data well established, could participate into
other response pathways, notably that of
conventional chemotherapy used in AML,
at least in part, through oxidative stress
activation of senescence.
Thank you.
Yeah, sure. Luca.
Does this work?
Yeah.
Yeah. Hi.
Luca Mazzarella from Milan.
So this is a little bit from an APL aficionado.
So in your model,
the PML-RA has basically
a dominant, and if we want, exclusive role on the
pathogenesis of APL. So yes, you may have additional
mutations, but they are not required, right?
Yeah.
So you know very well that one of the
long-discussed themes in the field has been the reason for the latency in the
development of APL in PML-RA transgenic mice.
So I was wondering, a couple of decades after these mice were
generated, and with all the new knowledge that we now have on PML-RA,
what's your take on this issue? Are additional mutations needed
for the APL development, or they're dispensable?
And if they are, what happens in the mouse in that latency period?
I think that's a very good question, which has really been
not fully addressed in the field. I think your work demonstrated that
there is a metabolic insight, in part through
lipid metabolism that has been studied, and this could suggest that even though the
genetic makeup
of these leukemic cells is okay, they need to adjust
for some other features, such as metabolism, which may
explain why indeed in PML-RA transgenic mice,
even though it's clearly a single hit disease, the mice do not get
leukemia immediately. It takes a couple of months.
There are other example of this in the cancer field, where you can have all
oncogenes activated,
everything fully on, but it still takes a while for the cells to grow,
and this could
reflect metabolic adaptation to allow growth.
In that respect,
Scott Kogan has demonstrated that even adding a single
MYC allele, going from MYC disomy to trisomy with, of course,
a major metabolic impact, is enough to
change these pre-leukemic cells into very rapidly
growing leukemic cells.
Yes, there is a question from the back, please.
Yeah. Hi. Saar Gill from the University of Pennsylvania.
I was wondering
your opinion on why isn't there APL for all
other
types of myeloid subsets, early myeloid
subsets. Why don't we see the same sort of syndrome and the same
sort of transcription factor combination for
the myelocytes, the metamyelocytes?
What is special about promyelocytes?
Hard question. Well, I'm sure you know that many
myeloid leukemia are driven by altered transcription factors.
So disruption of transcriptional control is obviously a common theme in
myeloid leukemia, as it is in sarcoma and other
conditions.
I think we're now dealing with a collection of orphan diseases, and that you have
probably thousands or tens of thousands of ways to
transform
a non-growing post-mitotic cell into a growing leukemic
cell. Then
there's probably no limit in nature's imagination to
generate these kind of
diseases.
Thanks.
I have a one-
Do we have questions? No, no questions from the chat.
I have a final question.
You mentioned that in the mouse models, the immune system is largely dispensable,
not necessary for the full eradication.
I'm wondering to what extent do you think that's true in patients?
Do you think that there is a role for immune system involvement?
I don't know if it's true. It's very difficult to assess.
I think you have to realize that the efficacy of
therapy in APL is incredibly fast.
It's monogenic disease,
very genetically stable. When you treat with retinoic acid
arsenic, the disease virtually disappears in three weeks, and so probably you
don't have time to accumulate resistant
cells, and
besides, the differentiation, which is massive, has an incredible debulking
effect also. So
all of this suggests that perhaps there is some immune intervention,
but very clearly in the mice models, it's not required.
Okay, if we have no further questions,
I think the next speaker is
Christopher
Sarosiek, I hope I pronounced it correctly, from Harvard School of
Public Health, and you'll be talking about
self-death regulation.
Yeah.
Thank you so much.
That was a wonderful talk.
So it's a huge honor to be here. Thank you so much for inviting me to
present some of our work today. We are very interested also in this
question on the differences that underlie differences
in sensitivity of solid tumors as well as liquid cancers to
common chemotherapeutic agents.
And so that's what I'll try to talk to you a little bit about today, and especially
our approach to trying to study this question.
These are my disclosures.So my lab really studies this key
question of what determines whether a cell will live or die in response to therapy.
Obviously, in the setting of trying to understand chemotherapy responses
in cancer cells, this has become a very important goal
of any therapy that we utilize. So I'll start out just by showing you
a very classic Kaplan-Meier curve for, in this
case, this high-grade serous ovarian cancer.
So we know that patients can either respond quite favorably to therapy and be on
the far right end of this curve, or it can actually succumb to
disease quite rapidly. And that's despite the fact that everyone's getting the same
type of treatment. So we know that there's heterogeneity in responses within a
cancer. But what I'd like to talk to you a little bit about today is the
differences or the heterogeneity in responses across cancers,
which I think is a really critical question that's not really studied as we silo
all these different cancer types in different sessions, even here at AACR.
So what I'm showing you here is actually a range of different Kaplan-Meier curves
for several different malignancies.
And first, I'll highlight several that are quite responsive to
therapy. So here we see T-ALL,
lymphoblastic leukemia,
diffuse large B-cell lymphoma, follicular lymphoma.
These are cancer types that are largely curable with the existing
regimens that we have today, many of which are going to target the same
types of cellular components that we're targeting in solid
tumors as well. One exception to the incurability or the
difficulty in treating of solid cancers is actually testicular
cancer. Germ cell tumors are profoundly sensitive to cisplatin.
With one therapy, you can actually cure a majority of these patients.
So these are very chemo-sensitive cancer types.
But then we know that there are many other types of cancers that, despite the fact
that we have the same drugs available, respond quite unfavorably to
therapies. Those include things such as sarcomas, hepatocellular carcinoma,
melanoma, and the high-grade serous ovarian cancer that I showed you on the
previous slide. And then we know that there's many
solid cancers, especially, that are profoundly resistant to therapy.
So that includes diseases such as pancreatic cancer, GBMs.
And we wanted to know what is potentially driving some of these major
differences in therapy responses between cancers.
So in the literature, and people would
give you several different types of answers to this question, one of which being,
well, we have different therapies for these different cancers, and that is largely
driving these differences. But if we just rank these cancers that I showed you on
the previous slide according to their outcomes and look at the therapies that we
use for their treatment, we actually see that we're targeting the same exact
cellular components. We're targeting DNA, we're targeting microtubules,
topoisomerases, and yet we can cure 90-plus percent of germ
cell tumors and 0% of GBMs. So clearly,
the applicability of the different therapy answer is
not quite sufficient to answer this.
And I also would like to point out that there's several different types of
therapies that we use largely in solid tumors that are actually
also going to be targeting the same thing in hematologic malignancies and
potentially are going to be even more active there, and I'll show you that in just
a couple seconds. So another potential
answer that's found in the literature is proliferation rates.
People say that the cycling rates of cancers is what really drives their
sensitivity. But if you actually dig a little bit deeper into some of the
actual studies of Ki-67 indexes and things like that, and look at
actual patient responses, you see that
explanation breaks down. And here's another good example of
that across the TCGA. If you just look at proliferating cell nuclear
antigen, mRNA levels, and you look at sensitivity to
therapy, again, here, judging by outcomes or based on
outcomes, you see that's a pretty poor indicator of response to therapy.
So if proliferation rates or different types of therapies aren't good
enough to explain why there's this difference between solid and liquid cancers,
then really what could be the explanation?
Well, we think that the wiring of the cell death pathways in these
cells is a major
contributor to these differences in responses.
And so we
are in particular interested in studying how apoptosis or programmed cell death
is regulated in cancers and may contribute to different responses.
So apoptosis is very important for sculpting our tissues, important
developmentally, and also is critical to understand that
most cancer therapies have used both cytotoxic as well as targeted agents,
as well as ionizing radiation produce pro-apoptotic signaling in cancer
cells. Don't always kill via apoptosis, but certainly produce that kind of
stress.
So how does this pathway actually wired?
So it's controlled by the BCL2 family of proteins.
These are going to be mobilized in response to a range of different death and
stress stimuli. Usually, there's some type of upstream signaling that is
first activated. P53 is a good example, ER stress response,
kinase inhibition. This leads to the production of proapoptotic
activator proteins such as Bim, Bid, and Puma, that can do one of two
things. One is that they can translocate to the mitochondria, where they can be
bound and sequestered by pro-survival proteins, BCL2, BCL-XL,
Mcl1.
If these are sequestered, the cell can stay alive and is not able to be
evident that there's any kind of morphological change or any biochemical change
even.
However, once we overwhelm these pro-survival proteins, something a little bit
different happens, which is that the Bim and Bid molecules can actually bind to Bax
and Bak, the pore-forming proapoptotic proteins, and cause the
permeabilization of the mitochondrial outer membrane.
Once this happens, cytochrome C is released into the cytoplasm, where it binds to
Apaf-1 and activates caspases. Now, caspases are the
executioners of apoptotic cell death and actually prepare the cell for phagocytic
clearance. So based on the BCL2 family protein interactions,
we can already start to imagine that the different states at the level of the
mitochondria may lead to different cell fates.
So here I'm showing you a cell that has pro-survival proteins, but they're already
sequestering pro-death signals.
We refer to this cell as being primed for apoptosis because when this cell is now
challenged with chemotherapy treatment, it's very easy to now trigger
Bax and Bak activation and the release of cytochrome C in the rest of the
cascade.In this other cell, however, we see that there are some
pro-survival proteins unbound. In this case, when we first challenge the
cell with some type of therapy,
those initial apoptotic signals can be sequestered, the cell stays
alive. It takes additional treatment to actually be able to trigger cell
death in the cell. We refer to this as being unprimed.
Finally, we have a separate type of scenario here, where we're actually
missing the pore-forming proteins entirely.
It doesn't matter how much proapoptotic signaling we produce in these cells
with the existing therapies, we will never trigger apoptotic cell death because Bax
and Bak are missing. I'll give you a sigh of relief.
It's a vast minority of cancers that actually have this apoptosis
refractory state. Most cancers are actually going to be in that primed or unprimed
category. However, many of our healthy tissues are exactly this way, and that's
what protects them from a lot of chemotherapeutic treatments.
So based on this understanding, we can already start to think, well, if we can
understand the state of the cell before therapy is administered,
perhaps that will give us some clues as to how the cancers are going to respond.
So Tony Letai, the current NCI director, actually developed this really neat assay
called BH3 profiling that measures apoptotic priming.
And I don't have the time to go into it in detail, but it's basically,
the idea is to titrate in doses of proapoptotic signals, BH3
peptides, that mimic the activity of the full-length BH3-only proteins.
In this case, we're titrating in the BIM peptide, which can bind
and inactivate the pro-survival proteins, but then activate Bax and Bak.
And then we can use a very simple readout of cytochrome C release to know whether
that cell has undergone that mitochondrial permeabilization or not using antibody
staining.
So then we can run this on flow cytometry and look at the populations of cells
that actually release cytochrome C versus those that do not, and we can score them
and give them a priming designation.
So we set out a long time ago to first check whether apoptotic priming actually
affects whether patients respond well to cancer therapies.
And so we used this in ovarian cancer to first look at whether there
are differences in priming. We saw indeed that there were differences.
Some ovarian primary tumors were highly primed for apoptosis, while others were
fairly resistant. When we looked at patient outcomes, we saw that those that
had more primed cancers had faster normalization of
CA125, indicating a faster clinical response,
also had improved progression-free survival.
Now, colleagues in Letai lab have also found that this was the case in chronic
lymphocytic leukemia and AML.
However, this is not what I set out to talk about today.
I really wanted to get at this question of what about across different cancer
types? What can we learn from the same type of assay and the same type of
analyses about the differences between cancers?
Well, one thing that we wanted to know first is wanted to know whether different
cancer cell lines reflect the sensitivity of the
cancers that they come from to therapies.
So here I'm showing you a range of different cancer cell lines from the DepMap
database and showing their sensitivity to cisplatin.
And these are just scored according to their IC50s, with
the ones on the left side being more sensitive.
And what becomes very clear very quickly is that blood cancers
such as lymphocytic leukemias, B cell leukemias,
other lymphoid neoplasms, are more sensitive to even
cisplatin, which is a drug typically used for solid tumors, than the
solid cancers on the right side that this drug is actually used for more
commonly.
If we take a step back and look at all DNA-damaging agents and score their
responses across these cancer cell lines, we see that it largely
reflects a very similar paradigm.
Blood cancers are dramatically more sensitive to these
DNA-damaging agents than solid cancer cell lines, especially ones that are
highly resistant to these treatments in patients.
Some of the clear outliers here are things such as testicular cancer
cells, which
continue to be very sensitive, reflecting their sensitivity in
patients as well. Taking a further step back, what if we look at
all cytotoxic drugs? Again, we see the same trend coming up.
Blood cancers, dramatically more sensitive to these therapies than solid
cancer cell lines.
And in fact, even if you look at all the targeted agents, many of which were
actually developed for solid cancer cells, you still
see that the blood cancers are more sensitive.
So this points to very clearly that there is some kind of
inherent cell-intrinsic sensitivity of blood cancer cells to
a wide range of different therapies.
Now, we wanted to know whether apoptotic priming is capable of giving us a major
difference in therapy outcomes. So we used an isogenic system, HeLa cells.
We knocked out Bax and Bak to blunt the apoptotic sensitivity of these
cells, and then we performed BH3 profiling and a range of chemosensitivity
analyses. When we remove Bax or Bak or both Bax and
Bak, we see that there's a decrease in apoptotic priming in these cells.
We are suppressing the apoptosis pathway, and we can see that based on the BH3
profiling assay. When we challenge these cells with a range of different
chemotherapeutic agents, we see exactly what we would expect to see.
They become dramatically more resistant to a wide range of different
chemotherapeutic agents.
And this is also true if we look at colony formation assays.
These cells are not only able to survive longer, but they're actually able to grow
out and survive and potentially
lead to things such as tumor recurrence in patients.
So when we apply this BH3 profiling technique to a range of cancer
cell lines, we see that there are definitely differences between them.
And when we summarize them by cancer type, we see that this again reflects what we
saw clinically, which is that these blood cancers that are more
sensitive to therapies in the clinic, also the cancer cell lines end up
being more primed for apoptosis. Interestingly, we also see that
pediatric CNS cancers and the cell lines coming from them, such
as medulloblastoma cell lines, also highly primed for apoptosis.
That's also one of the outliers. We know that we can cure about 80% to 90%
of pediatric medulloblastoma patients with existing cytotoxic
chemotherapy and radiation.The most resistant
cancer types on the right side ended up also being more resistant
to these proapoptotic signals And so when we look at the correlation
between the priming and the actual sensitivity to
chemotherapeutic agents, we see that it's pretty well
aligned with at least a third of the differences in
chemotherapy sensitivity potentially being able to be explained by differences in
apoptotic priming.
Now, this is another analysis that we performed on about 150
different cancer cell lines to look at their sensitivity to
agents that directly target the BCL2 family proteins, including
drugs that target BCLXL, BCL2, and MCL1.
Now, I don't expect you to look at the details here, but what I just wanted to
point out is that the only cancer cell lines that actually exhibit
single agent sensitivity to these drugs targeting BCL2 family
proteins are really blood cancers and some pediatric
CNS tumor cell lines, indicating that in most solid cancer cell
lines, you actually have to go and hit at least two or maybe even
three of these pro-survival proteins before you can actually induce cell death.
Again, pointing to this difference between solid and liquid cancers.
We also wanted to test this in primary cancer.
So we collected either primary material from patients directly
in a clinic or from genetically engineered mouse models and compared
the priming in the cancers that we were able to
analyze.
What we found was quite
interesting and reflected what we had seen in the cell lines.
We saw that when we looked at chronic lymphocytic leukemia primary specimens,
follicular lymphoma, AML specimens, they were primed for apoptosis.
Testicular cancer also primed for apoptosis.
Ovarian cancer, interestingly, had a large spread.
There was a lot of heterogeneity to it, and perhaps that's underlying some of the
differences and potential cures that we see in a subset of these.
Breast cancers were less primed than those.
And then as we went out further and further, we saw that some of the cancers that
are least chemosensitive in patients are also those that are
least primed for apoptosis, including pancreatic cancer and adult
rhabdomyosarcoma, hepatocellular carcinoma.
We then set out to, of course, one, it's a study.
Well, what is actually driving the level or what is determining the level of
apoptotic priming in these cancer cells?
And we've examined a range of different things, including metabolic effects,
changes in oncogenes. There's a range of different things that we studied.
I don't have the time to go into each one of those in detail.
I'll just tell you what ended up being the most dominant factor,
which, as I've already sort of alluded to, ends up being the cell of
origin. And we really found that out by
performing tumor genesis studies.
So we looked at the apoptotic priming in the cell of origin or the tissue of origin
versus the cancers that emerged from them.
And in this case, this is the KPC mouse model of pancreatic cancer driven
by KRAS and P53 loss. When we compared the level of
priming in the normal pancreas versus the pan in early
lesions versus the full-blown pancreatic cancer, we saw that there was a
trend toward increased apoptotic priming.
When we looked at the genetic changes that underlie this, transcriptional
changes, we saw that there was a huge upregulation of proapoptotic signaling,
proapoptotic mRNAs
related to expression of Bax and Bak, as well as many of the proapoptotic proteins
that I previously mentioned, indicating that as cells are transforming into a
tumor cell, they are also experiencing apoptotic stress.
This was also the case in the Madd-2 model of hepatocellular carcinoma
and was also the case in high-grade serous ovarian cancer, where we looked at
healthy fallopian tube epithelial cells as well as borderline tumors and then
full-blown high-grade serous ovarian cancers.
So this gave us the clue that potentially the shifts from a
normal cell to a tumor cell was
associated with an increase in priming, but then that starting cell was
potentially a key determinant of where the final tumors ended up.
And so we looked at the healthy cells and the healthy tissues where all the
other cancers had originated from to compare that level of priming.
And so for CLL and follicular lymphoma, they originate from peripheral B cells, and
we saw that those cells are also extremely highly primed for apoptosis.
Hematopoietic stem cells, the precursors for AMLs
also highly primed for apoptosis.
Normal testicular germ cells quite primed and
linked to that level of the priming that we see in testicular cancer.
In the fallopian tube epithelial cells, we see that they are also sensitive to
these apoptotic signals. And again and again, as we went down the line, we see
that the tissues that these cancers are originating
from have differences in their apoptotic priming that then reflect the cancer that
arises from them.
So we can just run a quick correlational analysis and see something quite
interesting popping up,
which is that hematologic malignancies are by far the
most primed cancers that we have studied, and they actually
are just as primed as the precursors they come from.
And so interestingly, we think that their precursors are so highly
primed that they actually need to undergo this evasion of apoptosis that we
know is a hallmark of cancer development.
However, in many other cancer types that originate from solid tumors and
from cells that are extremely resistant to apoptosis at
the starting point, we actually don't think that they have to undergo this evasion
of apoptosis because they actually have a huge buffer built into them.
And so as they get slightly more stressed during this tumor genesis process,
they can still maintain that survival without having to
dysregulate the apoptosis pathway.So
as a final vignette, we wanted to show you
this
interesting idea about, well, if we could change the starting
point of a cancer cell, would it potentially lead to a difference in the
priming and chemosensitivity of the tumor that emerged?
And this was work done with David Kirsch.
He's an expert in pediatric rhabdomyosarcoma, has this really wonderful
model of
inducible rhabdomyosarcoma that we utilize for these studies.
So rhabdomyosarcoma can arise in pediatric as well as
adult individuals, and the actual
outcomes are quite different. In pediatric, in children or adolescents,
they're quite a bit more chemosensitive, and radiation sensitive
than those in adults. So we wanted to model this, and so we
utilized a kind of a trick, which is that we've previously found
that healthy tissues in young individuals are actually more primed for
apoptosis than in adults. That's because as tissues are growing and
remodeling, you actually need to utilize that apoptosis pathway to prune cells
that are superfluous or damaged. And so we
looked in a skeletal muscle of young mice, so this P1 to P5, so
neonatal mice versus adult mice. And we saw that the
muscle satellite cells in the young mice were much more primed for
apoptosis. And so we took advantage of David Kirsch's system
to induce K-RAS activation and knockout of p53
in these muscle satellite cells and drove the development of rhabdomyosarcomas,
either from neonatal or adult mice.
They were essentially identical when it came to histology and other parameters
that were reflecting the actual disease state.
But when we looked at the apoptotic priming in the pediatric versus adult
rhabdomyosarcomas, we saw that they were different.
The pediatric tumors that emerged from the young muscle were more
primed for apoptosis than the adult. And you can see that, here.
So then we wanted to know, well, does that then lead to a difference in the
sensitivity to therapy in this cancer?
And so we, again, induced these tumors,
treated them with the standard of care, which is vincristine for
rhabdomyosarcoma. And we saw that while the adult rhabdomyosarcoma were completely
insensitive to this treatment, the pediatric ones actually had some
response. Wasn't a very satisfying response, but we saw something that
was better than the adult. When we looked at the underlying molecular
biology here to try to understand what's driving these differences in
priming between these two different settings, we saw that
the young muscle actually had higher levels of these pro-apoptotic proteins,
which was then reflected in the tumors that emerged from them.
So the higher Bax levels in the young mice led to that higher level of
priming and was maintained in the cancers that emerged.
We also saw higher levels of pro-apoptotic Bim, and interestingly, also very high
levels of BCL-XL and MCL1, which then led us to hypothesize that
perhaps if we sensitize these tumors
using tools such as BCL-XL inhibitors, we could then improve the
responses to therapy in this model.
And so we did exactly that. We treated these mice with not only vincristine, but
also combined it with a BCL-XL degrader DT2216,
and we saw that they actually responded much more favorably, which
indicates to us that BH3 mimetics are
one method that we can use to sensitize some of these very
unprimed cancers, and actually get an improvement in
responses in patients.
So that just brings us to the kind of the conclusions in the model that we have
here. I didn't go into the Myc versus RAS differences, but we see oncogenes
being able to modulate this property in cells during transformation.
But really the idea that we were left with is that
the cancer cells that emerge
are largely dependent on the apoptosis pathway in
the starting cell. So in this case, an epithelial cell is going to yield a
cancer cell that has a
certain level of priming reflecting that,
and that's driven largely by oncogenes increasing or decreasing that level of
priming. However, cancer cells that come from
very highly primed precursors such as B cells, T cells, or young
tissues such as young muscle or young brain cells, actually are set to
be much more highly primed to start with.
And alternatively, those that come from cells in adult
terminally differentiated tissues that are very apoptosis restricted
end up being very unprimed. And so we think that the future lies,
hopefully in some use of priming agents that can help us increase
the sensitivity of these resistant cancers.
So with that, I'd just like to thank the great individuals that did this work in my
lab, especially Xing Ping and Cam Frazier, who have been fantastic
at doing all the in vitro and in vivo experiments.
And thank you all so much for your attention.
Thank you very much. Questions for Christopher.
Hi, Chris.
Thank you very much for your talk, great data, and of course, very
appealing to think of a priming that is predefined and
can maybe translate even into the cancers.
You group the hematopoietic cancers together,
mostly.
And,
we've just seen that the venetoclax data for the MDSs or the
myelodysplastic syndromes have failed in a third line in
a phase III trial to really make any benefit.
Do you think the availability of the compounds at
the correct site within the cell, is it the right compound that we don't have
yet, or is it the right way of applying them that is missing?
Because when can we really translate this priming into clinical efficacy?
Yeah, it's a great question. And I should mention that I am lumping
together a lot of heme malignancies, and we know that there are some that are very
difficult to control. AML is a great example of that.
A huge tumor burden, very high mutation rate, very aggressive cancer,
so much harder to overcome or target with these therapies.
When it comes to
what are we still missing for some of these heme malignancies and
targeting apoptosis, I think a lot of it is redundancy
between some of these BCL2 family proteins.
And we have a great BCL2 inhibitor that's already clinically
approved for a subset of cancers in AML, in combination also
very effective. But we need more of these same drugs that can
take care of the rapid adaptation that ends up happening in
these cells in order to preclude the development of resistance.
We see that every time we apply a BCL2 inhibitor onto cells, we see an
upregulation of MCL1 and BCL-XL. We need to come up with really
rational,
reasonable ways to be able to target those escape mechanisms
in order to get these durable responses that we're really looking for in such
fast-growing cancers.
Thank you for the really cool talk.
I was wondering if we could speculate
exercise as one of the priming factors.
And I say that because you mentioned
property
in the young muscle tissue, and muscle is related to
being very metabolically active.
More muscle, the processes that need to develop
more muscle would involve a lot of remodeling, therefore injury and
repair and higher apoptosis by
definition. So could one of the priming factors
be, let's say, resistance training?
Wow, that's an interesting question.
I think that with a lot of what we're talking about here with the
priming, has to do more with the precursors.
So if the cells themselves are remodeling as they are in
a young growing
tissue, if that becomes a cancer,
then you have that memory of the starting point in that cell, and it makes it
more treatable. We don't have evidence showing that a
growing muscle is releasing some kind of factors that it then is priming
other cells to undergo apoptosis and potentially would
make them more sensitive to therapy.
That being said, there are some really interesting studies being done out
there doing certain kinds of muscle stimulation to
release exosomes that might speak to
cancer cells in interesting ways and make them more
chemosensitive. I think that there's evidence now that people
that utilize more exercise have better therapy
responses. There's a lot of confounding factors there,
obviously. But that's an interesting idea that might be worth
looking at, especially if you can nail down just exactly what's being released
during exercise, and if you can identify a factor that is driving those
responses, that could be an interesting avenue.
Thank you.
Hi.
That was a great talk. So my question could be a little naive, but
in your study, did you come across any sex-dependent
diversity in the priming for cancer across-
Sorry, you said any sex-based differences in priming?
Yes.
That's a great question.
Honestly, we haven't looked
very deeply at that. We did one study where we looked at the developing
brain and looked for differences between priming in
neural stem cells between male and female mice.
We didn't see much of a difference, which we are actually looking for because we
know that there's differences in radiation toxicity in
pediatric patients that receive radiation therapy, male
versus female. And so we were looking for potential differences there, and we
didn't see anything. So we haven't done it exhaustively, and I
think that it would be an interesting thing to continue looking upon.
But we didn't see it in the studies thus far.
Thank you.
Thanks for your question.
Hey, Chris. Excellent talk. I don't know if you remember me.
I'm with Matt Davids at DFCI.
Oh, yeah. You look familiar.
And as someone who's learning BH3 profiling, I
had two questions based off of your talk.
Sure.
I know you're showing a lot of data comparing heme malignancies and solid cancers.
And I was wondering if you were using microscopy-based or flow-based
assays or a mixture of the two when you were doing the direct
comparisons between those two types of cancers.
Yeah. This is all flow cytometry-based.
Okay.
Yeah, we kept that the same. But yeah, there's ways to do it via microscopy,
plate-based methods. There's a lot of approaches.
And the second question was, you showed a lot of baseline priming, and I was
curious if the dynamic profiles were different amongst solid versus heme cancers.
Oh, yeah. Great question. So
all of this was just based on the baseline sensitivity
of these cells. So we didn't perturb them with anything and look at responses.
But that's another really neat area where Tony has shown that you can
find early evidence of apoptotic signaling and detect it with BH3
profiling assays. So in these studies, I'm really just showing the baseline.
We have done some of that, and we're really interested in looking at things such as
radiation therapy, how that's altering the priming of the
cells. And sometimes you see very obvious changes where you're seeing an
upregulation of apoptotic signaling, increased priming.
But sometimes you actually see suppression, and the dynamics of that
are really interesting to us, and we want to try to understand that in order to
more rationally combine agents for effective therapeutics.
So yeah.
Be happy to chat more about that.
Great.
Thank you very much.
So we'll listen now to the last talk
by Luca Mazzarella from the European Institute of
Oncology in Milan.
So hi. Good afternoon, everybody.
Thanks a lot, Hugh, for the kind invitation.
So I'm going to
tell you about a story that we've developed over the years in the lab,
which we think led to a novel understanding of
an old
tumor suppressor,
which is of general interest across different tumors, as you will see.
So NF1, which takes its name from this
genetic disease called neurofibromatosis, which has at the same time predisposition
to cancer and neurodevelopmental defects,
was very early on identified to be caused by loss
of function mutations of this gene, which turned out to be one of the
earliest tumor suppressors ever cloned back in
1991 by Francis Collins. And very early on, it
was noticed that NF1 had structural homology with
a GTPase activating protein that had as their
target Ras.
And so it was discovered very early on that you
could isolate the GRD domain, the
GAP-related domain
of NF1. NF1 is a huge protein that
is very difficult to produce in recombinant fashion.
I always like to tell that if you want to make it into
bacteria, you have to so heavily optimize
the codons that the sequence eventually doesn't blast to the
original NF1 sequence anymore. But it was
easy and feasible to isolate the Ras
interacting domain. And therefore, for many, many years, I would
say the vast majority of the research on NF1 has been
carried out with the founding idea that NF1 acts as a
GTPase activating protein for Ras.
And therefore, the disease that comes from it is considered to be a Rasopathy, so a
disease where you have constitutive activation of Ras.
And also in cancer genomics, of course, everyone is used to
thinking of NF1 as an activator of
Ras.
And this comes from the recent papers that
revealed the structure of NF1. NF1 is a dimer
that has two main conformations,
closed or open, depending on the possibility to interact with Ras.
And as you can see in the model, basically, everything takes place at
the plasma membrane on this upper
convex face of NF1.
But hardly anything happens on this other side.
And so, one wonders what all this protein structure is there
to do if basically everything happens in these two small
domains.
So we got interested in NF1 because a few years ago, we were
looking at genes that are differentially mutated between metastatic and
primary breast cancer, and specifically in
HER2-positive breast cancer. By comparing different data sets, we
realized that NF1, together with P53,
is
one of the most differentially mutated genes in the genome.
So we got interested in this also because HER2-positive breast cancer, as you all
know, is almost invariably treated
also in the adjuvant setting with anti-HER2 therapies.
And therefore, the presence of something that is enriched in the metastatic setting
is most likely either due to a favoring of the
metastatic phenotype, but also possibly to resistance to different
therapies. This was the original idea, and that was the reason why
we decided to conduct-- We CRISPR knocked out
NF1 in several models, cell models, several models of HER2-positive breast
cancer. And we conducted a screen of different drugs, both
chemotherapy and targeted drugs that are normally used
in HER2-positive breast cancer. We were right in our hypothesis, which is
actually scooped while we were preparing the paper by a group in New
York. And so old school
HER2-targeting therapies
were certainly less
effective in the NF1 knockout cells.
But we were quite struck by
a totally serendipitous finding, which was that the
cells became instead more sensitive to T-DM1 antibody drug
conjugate that I'm sure you all know.
But just as a recap,
sorry, is a conjugation of trastuzumab that targets HER2
positive with a linker
that carries a payload which is DM1 that belongs to a class of drugs called the
maytansinoids that have a peculiarity.
They are microtubule binding drugs, and they are the only
microtubule binding drug where the binding site actually sits at the
interface between two alpha-beta heterodimers
that are incorporated in the microtubule.
And you will see that this is important for
the mechanism of action.
Is it? Yeah, sorry. I don't know why
the resolution is so bad. But so this is to show
that if you
look at the effect of the drug over time,
where some of the differences become more
obvious, and then you see that T-DM1, the gray
line, is the wild-type cell, and the knockout cell is in blue.
You see that there is a huge difference, this is on a log scale, in the
growth
curve in response to T-DM1 of these cells.
But then if you split the drug between trastuzumab and DM1, because we really
wanted to know whether this differential activity was due to the antibody part,
different incorporation of the drug, or other things that could be
attributed to the antibody or to the payload.
The payload was really able tophenocopy the treatment with
the whole antibody drug conjugate.
And so basically, and importantly, you do not
obtain the same differential with another antibody drug conjugate where the payload
is different and it's a topoisomerase inhibitor like TDXD.
We could demonstrate that this differential effect can also be elicited in
mice. We did experiments where we implanted in the two flanks of
NSG mice, wild type or knockout cells.
We treated the mice with the same dose of DM1, and you
see that very clearly, the knockout cells
responded much, much better to the same drug.
And also we could assemble a cohort of patients across the world.
It was a very difficult work. Eventually, we ended up
with 34 patients, for which
we had both treatment and genomics
informations. And there was clearly a difference, a statistically
significant difference in progression-free survival in the NF1 mutated
patients.
And importantly, if you then try to make the same
experiment with oncogenic RAS, so we expressed in the
same cells where we had knocked out NF1,
the oncogenic version of RAS, a
G12V mutation, you do not get any
differential sensitivity whatsoever.
So this was one of the first indications that this differential sensitivity
is at least not replicated by
RAS hyperactivation.
Another thing that we noticed was that these cells
exhibit a mitotic defect. So if you look at the length of
mitosis in the knockout cells, you can clearly appreciate that the length is
significantly longer, and you can appreciate a number of mitotic
abnormalities like lagging chromatids, that
eventually result in a statistically significant difference
in the fraction of cells with misaligned chromosomes,
which importantly is entirely rescued when you re-express
the wild-type version of NF1. And this
importantly, can also be seen in patients, because if you look
at the Gini data and you
calculate the aneuploidy score, you see the NF1 mutants
tend to have a higher aneuploidy score.
I don't know what's wrong with the slides, but
they were fine on my computer, so
sorry about that.
But so
what does NF1 have to do with microtubules?
Because there was no strong evidence,
definitely it's not dependent on RAS.
And the
connection between NF1 and microtubules has been sort
of lingering in the literature for many, many years because this was actually
one of the earliest findings. If you try to purify NF1
from insect cells, tubulin co-precipitates with neurofibromin, but it
was never really followed up very much.
So we decided to investigate a little bit more on this.
And first of all, one of the things that we did was to look at the
intracellular localization of NF1,
because as I mentioned before, the existing model
postulates that basically everything happens at the cell membrane for the
interaction with RAS. But in fact, we did not find any strong evidence
of NF1 localization in the plasma membrane or in any other membrane.
Instead, we did find a localization on the mitotic
spindle, and which was also confirmed by proximity
localization assay.
And then if you try to
look at the interaction in vitro, then this becomes very, very evident, because if
you purify NF1 and you co-sediment it with
microtubules, it actually precipitates together with
polymerized microtubules, as you see in the co-sedimentation assay on the
left. And also, if you visualize the interaction by
negative staining and electron microscopy, you can see a very nicely
decorated microtubule in the
images on the right. And so NF1, it doesn't simply stick to
the microtubules. It actually
alters the polymerization dynamics of tubulin.
So we did this old-fashioned tubulin polymerization assay where all you
measure is the
turbidity of the solution where tubulin is polymerizing in
microtubules, and this
normally follows a sigmoidal shape over time, where at the beginning you have a
lagging phase with nucleation of early microtubules, then a linear
phase where the microtubules start growing very fast, and then a steady
state where the rate of incorporation and elimination is
fixed.
And what we could see was that this is the standard
sigmoidal curve that you see for normal tubulin polymerization.
The addition of the maytansinoid drug, as you can see, completely abrogated
any polymerization. But then you see that when you add
recombinant NF1 in the solution, the whole curve is massively
shifted to the left. And also the addition of DM1, it
doesn't really make any difference.
So it's actually in a reductionist system where there's
no additional protein, there's no RAS or anything else, NF1 is
directly able to accelerate polymerization of tubulin and
to counteract the activity of the drug.
We looked even more carefully at that in these in vitro assays where you
can make seeds of microtubules that you can see here in
magenta. They are stabilized by taxol, and then you add in the solution
green fluorescent tubulin that is used to visualize
the growth and shrinkage, the so-called dynamic instability of the
microtubules. And you can clearly see that in the presence of NF1,
the microtubules are way more dynamic and the growth rate is accelerated.
But also when you treat with the drugs, you see on the left that the
addition of DM1 basically almost completely abolishes any growth.
But as you start adding NF1, the more you add, the more you
counteract this activity, and the microtubules are able to grow
despite the presence of DM1.And you can also
show the same thing in vivo because you can transfect the cells with a
reporter that produces a
fluorescent protein, the EB3
GFP bound, that
binds to the tips of the microtubules, and so you are able
to track
with live cell imaging the growth rate of the
microtubules. And if you focus on the two quadrants on the bottom, you clearly
see that the dynamics of the microtubules on
the right, which are the knockout cells treated with DM1, is almost
nonexistent compared to some residual
dynamics of the microtubules that you have on the left in the wild-type cells.
Once again, showing that clearly there is an effect of the drug and an
interaction with the genotype at the level of microtubules.
More specifically, what we found was that the
NF1 doesn't only seem to enhance the dynamic
instability, which is the classical property of microtubules, but
in particular, it seems that, as you will see in the experiments that
I show now, that it seems to impact on
a relatively recently identified phenomenon that occurs in
microtubules, which is that of the self-repair and the
intra-tubular damage. So recent papers coming out in
the last decade or so
demonstrated that microtubules tend to
accumulate sites of damage or tubulin eviction or
irregularities within the body of the microtubule.
This could be due to mechanical stress, to oxidative stress,
to the motor proteins
sort of
walking, crawling on the microtubules themselves, which leads to the
eviction of some
tubulin dimers. And these little holes can accumulate and expand over
time. But at the same time, there is a
self-repair process that leads to the reincorporation of GTP
tubulin within the microtubule
shaft. It's currently unknown if this is a
completely spontaneous process.
It's known that this happens in a completely self-sufficient
way, but it's not known whether in the cell environment this
is regulated by additional proteins, because the
kinetics of this process seems to be different between in vitro and in vivo.
So we set up to measure this. Again, sorry, this
figure is completely screwed up. But just to show that we
developed a methodology to basically, again, use
fixed microtubules in magenta,
created in conditions that lead to the accumulation of this damage and the
subsequent addition of a green fluorescent tubulin to identify and
quantify sites of repair.
You can
visualize here that,
I hope this still remains visible, that when you
add the drug, basically you start seeing the accumulation of these
huge holes in the middle of the microtubule that sometimes lead to
basically complete fracturing of the microtubule.
And then no green fluorescent
tubulin added whatsoever because the drug completely inhibits this
self-repair mechanism. But as you add NF1 in the
presence of the same amount of drug, now you start seeing that the
microtubule is very efficiently repaired.
But can you measure the same thing, the same phenomenon, in vivo?
So is this
activity of NF1, of neurofibromin on the in vitro microtubules
also measurable in vivo? And in order to
do that, you could also use for injection of fluorescent tubulin in
cells, but this is very cumbersome and associated with toxicity.
So we resorted to an indirect marker of
EB1 that was demonstrated previously to
change its positioning along the microtubules
when the only other factor known to be involved in
microtubule repair, the CLASP protein, is knocked out.
And you can see here on the right that when you knock down
CLASP, the positioning of EB1, which at the beginning
in the wild-type cells is positioned on the tips of the microtubules,
then it starts repositioning along the microtubule
body. And, sorry, again, the resolution is very
bad. Hopefully, it's still visible here.
If you take wild-type cells and you immune stain
with EB1, after 15 or 45 minutes of treatment with
the drug, you start seeing the strong accumulation of
DM1 along the microtubule shaft. But
interestingly, when you look at the same process in the knockout, at the
beginning you start having a similar accumulation, but then the
binding of EB1 is completely lost over 45 minutes,
and the fragmentation of the microtubules is significantly
increased.
Showing that EB1, after an initial spreading throughout the
microtubule, basically the microtubules were so damaged that
they started depolymerizing completely, and EB1 detached completely.
And also you can see exactly the same thing in mitotic cells
without any treatment with DM1. Here
we had to use super resolution microscopy
because this was particularly hard to do
in the complex mitotic cells. But I hope you can clearly appreciate that the
distribution of EB1 is radically different in the knockout cells, where
you start having a distribution of EB1 along the mitotic spindle, and
this can be quantified. And also the microtubules are also
more fragmented in this context. And this led us to a model in which
basically when you have some mechanical stress in the middle of the
microtubuleNF1 is able to accelerate the
incorporation of new dimers of tubulin.
If you don't do that, what happens is that you start accumulating
open protofilament ends, which, as I told you at the beginning, act
as binding sites for maytansin, and therefore you can actually
demonstrate that in the knockout by using thermo
shift assays performed directly in the cells, which measure the
affinity, the number of binding sites for the drug on
their target, which in this case is tubulin.
You can clearly see a shift towards right of the curve,
suggesting that there are more binding sites for this drug in
the knockout cells.
But so then these are two extremely different functions.
So is NF1 a Ras inhibitor, or is
NF1 a microtubule fixer? I think we don't have
absolutely any final answer on this question.
So what I'm going to show you now is mostly
speculation, but
I just wanted to...
Two minutes, yes, don't worry.
I just wanted to stress that as I showed you at the beginning,
p53 is a very commonly
commutated gene in breast cancer.
And if you look at lung cancer, we looked recently at the lung
cancer studies from cBioPortal, you clearly see that there is a
statistically significant co-occurrence of these two mutations.
And also to move a little bit into liquid tumors, a recent
paper that specifically looked at the genomic landscape of p53
mutated myeloid malignancies identified NF1, you cannot read it there,
but it's the top co-mutated gene
together with p53.
I will jump this one. And so this led us to a model where we
started asking what may be the interaction between p53 and
NF1, and this comes from the recent paper by the Meitinger group, where they
showed that p53 acts as a mitotic
stopwatch, which detects whether the mitosis of a
cell has
taken too long and arrests the cells in the subsequent
interphase or subsequent mitosis.
So what we think happens is that when you have NF1 loss, the
initial effect is to activate Ras, and
in cells that are p53 proficient, the main effect is on Ras,
because the other effect, which, as I showed you, leads
to the prolongation of
mitosis, is basically cleared away
by p53 proficiency. So the few cells that take too long
to stay in mitosis, they are cleared away by p53.
And so p53 proficiency makes the Ras
effect the main one, the dominant one.
But in the absence of p53, then this
clearance of the
excessively long mitotic cells, and therefore those that accumulate and employ the,
and most likely microtubular damage does not happen, and therefore these cells
remain in the population, and these other effects are probably
becoming dominant. And this would lead to the
forecast that if you now re-correct the
p53 in a p53 deficient cells, then you would
not have this differential sensitivity between
the knockout and the wild type in the response to TDM1.
And we did exploit a
temperature-sensitive mutant
of p53 that you actually have endogenously in the
BT474 cell lines, which we analyzed, and this is
indeed the case, because when you grow the cells at 32 degrees,
p53 becomes proficient again, and you do not see this
selective sensitivity anymore.
So these are my take home messages.
We think we found a novel function for NF1 in modulating microtubule
repair, which is Ras independent, and it leads to mitotic defects and aneuploidy.
It's a clinically important biomarker because it's predictive of
maytansinoid efficacy, which is a key ADC payload besides
TDM1. We have now the approval of mirvetoximod suraftensin in
ovarian cancer, which is based on a maytansinoid drug.
These mutations tend to co-occur with p53
across multiple solid and liquid tumors, and we think that p53
deficiency or proficiency may determine which NF1 activity
is the dominant one. And microtubule damage, we think,
remains a poorly characterized phenomenon in cancer biology, which may be
important to study because it may have prognostic predictive role and a potential
therapeutic target. Thanks a lot for your attention.
So questions for Luca?
So I have one. Oh, please.
You mentioned that NF1 is a massive protein with,
I'm sure it has multiple domains. So
are there specific domains of this protein that are really
playing a key role in the function that you elucidated, and what
might they be?
Yeah. So of course, this is the next question that we're trying to elucidate.
So we've been working now for a couple of years in trying to resolve
by cryo-EM the neurofibromin microtubule
complex, and we also worked a bit with mutants, different mutants that were known
to abrogate RasGAP activity or other mutants
that we're trying to identify through high-throughput genetic screens.
And we don't yet have an answer for that.
What I can tell you is that we do have a clear model
for how the protein may bind the microtubule, and therefore what we
think is happening is that the binding interface between
neurofibromin and the microtubule is very wide, and so it's
very difficult to pinpoint single
nucleotide mutations that can lead to a complete loss of the binding.
We think that there are some crucial interfaces that we're trying to delete.
And also the other interesting thing that came out in recent experiments is
thatVery interestingly, mutants that are
defective for the RasGAP activity are also
defective for the microtubule repair
activity, but not through an inhibition
of binding to the microtubules. So it seems that mutants in the
RasGAP domain still bind to the microtubule, but
they fail to correct the repair.
That's something that is difficult to
reconcile with the existing literature,
and so we're working very hard to try and identify that.
But at the present time, there's no clearly
microtubule specific domain within NF1.
Thank you.
Other questions? I had one. With this completely new view
of the role of NF1, shouldn't we consider
also the level of expression
rather than only mutations, and could this modulate response to
microtubule targeting agents?
Well, it could be, although NF1 is in general a
ubiquitously expressed gene. There are no huge
fluctuations in the expression.
Also, the other important thing that I have to tell you is that we've
screened many antibodies for NF1, and they are all bad,
invariably. They are all non-specific.
There's only one that achieves some degree of specificity, but in other
assays it still remains non-specific.
So at the present time, that is actually a problem,
and it's not easy to look at actual
expression levels by existing reagents.
Okay. Well, if there are no further questions, join me in thanking the speakers
for this session.